turning off tonight's show with a brand
new 60 seconds and an interview Make
Some Noise sing along if you know the
words this is Hans Tim
thank you
I feel bad for the girls that have to
have sex with me
because after I finger them they're like
well that's the best that's gonna get
laughs
I'm glad affirmative action is now
illegal cause I'm sick of all these
minorities in my colleges
call me old-fashioned but I don't think
a college classroom should look like a
Dollar General
I think it should look like the
screening of sound of freedom
all white people
I love how white people are so bored
they're now rescuing other people's
children
[Music]
minorities we don't even care about our
own children that much
if I got molested my dad would be like
good
maybe this will make him better at
violin
[Laughter]
Hans Kim
[Applause]
fun stuff Hans I actually love that uh
finger joke that you did thank you Tony
that was amazing it's incredible that
you can still kick out new funny jokes
about your tiny Asian penis I thought
we've heard them all it's a gift that
keeps on giving
let the laugh come I like that people
were laughing and you're ready to talk
and you're like nah [__] it I'm gonna
count down from 60. let him laugh for a
couple more seconds
good for you
[__] molesting joke you are terrific
I enjoyed your life you started strong
you ended sexy
indeed you really did did your dad try
to make you uh learn violin or did you
did your Asian parents make you try to
do Asian things growing up can you give
us some examples of some of those things
um he wouldn't let me watch TV on at
night or on the weekends and uh I got
really mad and I punched a hole in the
wall
oh oh
like Asian to punch a hole through the
wall did you think about kicking the
wall first did you punch it like that
with like a hand
like pie May or something like that
perhaps
I just did an American boxing Style
ah okay [__] you dead oh wow wait that
was incredible that made us sound do it
again I hate you
the timing of it is just perfect can you
guys do it one more time it's incredible
to watch you two work together [__] you
amazing Hans Kim what else is going on
with you this week tell us more I uh
been killing it on the road I just did
uh a rally North Carolina which is great
it's a practice for my one minute and
then I have to fill in 59 minutes after
that wow
where was that at Raleigh North Carolina
okay did you open with the same joke
about fingering a girl that's a great
one on the road yeah it was it was in
there good for you but did you open with
it no okay yeah yeah I don't like really
that's a make or break joke they're
gonna love you or hate your guns yeah
it's a good temperature reading yeah
literally I like my dick
when you finger
when you finger a girl Hans what finger
do you use exactly I use the middle
finger whoa this guy's he's going for
distance
he's going for speed
yeah I [__] up I've used the thumb
that's a real hahaha
hitchhike I figure you might go with the
pinky this way when your dick you can
exceed the expectations of the pinky
you're [__] up throwing your biggest
finger out there do you have to let it
finger do you have to do you have to
um
so let's let me ask you this your middle
finger compared to your dick what is the
length and uh width difference there
yeah it's way bigger than my middle
finger okay when you say way bigger
can you give us an example would you
would it hurt Lena the plug if you uh
not everybody's on uh
The Tick Tock out here it's it's like a
dick it's not all right [__] it's not
like your dick Tony I heard some things
in the Grapevine that that's crazy
you've heard nothing about
okie dokie
God damn it I don't want people knowing
about my huge dicks
stop and Bear ing me in front of our
people
it's very very normal guys I'm just like
one of you
stop with the horse sounds
okay there's a lady squirting in the
corner right now
Hans anything else we should know about
you before continuing on
um I wrote I drove my girlfriend on my
moped but she was drunk she sort of
passed out on the back oh [__] yeah is
that a true I thought that was the setup
to a joke
yeah yeah that's uh she was on there
because she was sitting on my dick and
it didn't keep her on there very well
wait you had her in front of you no I
was just trying to put a punchline on it
uh
that's weird because if you actually
snake your dick back under you and wrote
A Lopez
yeah it's more like a ropey hard on uh
no no it was she was a ropey hard on
what's Happening you'll last a little
cattle with it yeah this [__] guy's a
Roper right here you guys this is his
name's actually ropey hard on I don't
know if you've met him before there's a
header and a Healer if you don't know
what I'm talking about you don't know
[__] about [__] because I know all about
it it's called uh Team Roping you know
what I mean and you just [__] you
take the rope and you just [__] swing
it around your [__] claw and then you
throw it out there like that
foreign
[Applause]
he's got a stapler for a right hand
I loved you in Jurassic Park
[Music]
I started tonight I love it you do it
every single week you will not have to
challenge for your spot next week I love
what you're doing I think you're uh
hitting pecans Kim career style a lot of
great new stuff lately I Love It Make
some noise for hunts Kim everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
the second name and now